is olympics something that is like  a goal of yours yeah for sure like a  legitimate one not just like i want to  go out there and try no i'm not just  running just around yeah i can do that  on the track somewhere yeah trying to  try and go to the olympics okay what's  that process like are you starting that  because i mean you know that's a whole  yes i'm in a boot right now so i can't i  can't do too much but uh next year i'm  gonna start back training for it every  off season training for 100 meter or 60  meter whichever one i decide to do yeah  um and then in 2024 you'll see me again  that is so cool like it has to happen  right oh yeah for sure it's gonna happen  yeah okay i love the confidence